so my name is Billy crando I am a Java
developer Advocate with Oracle and you
can find me on Twitter
um The Bird app at Billy crando where I
spend far too much of my time but please
don't tell my boss or any of my
co-workers Nikolai cover your ears
uh important information ask questions
though have a lot to get through so
maybe uh questions at the end and if I
don't get a chance to answer your
questions here again reach out to me on
Twitter you can DM me you can or you can
also send me an email at billy.crandall
Oracle as well
and the link to this presentation is at
this link so you can go check it out as
well if you want to kind of go back for
a reference as well
if you leave with an intense desire to
know more we have a lot of great uh
resources that that our team at the
Oracle devrel are Java devrel Oracle uh
put together check out dev.java
insight.java and our YouTube channel as
well
um but with that said let's actually
start getting into the presentation the
agenda we're going to have about four
five different areas first we're going
to look at some new language features
have been added from jdk 11 and on new
updates to apis new runtime features
replication removals and some other
important changes to know about and then
some of the preview and incubators out
there is also have been added
so let's first get into these new
language features and the first one I
want to cover is text blocks these were
added in Java 15 and the job for them is
378. so when I say Jeff that refers to
jdk enhancement proposal and let me get
a new
so yes oh well unfortunately I don't
have internet right now I forgot to
connect to it but I'll say if you go to
openjdk.org zero that will give you the
full list of all the different jeps that
are have been done or proposed to be
done and these are great sources and
then if you were to put in jeps 378
instead of zero to end there that will
bring up the jdk enhancement proposal
for text blocks which gives a lot of
great information background motivation
goals of the new feature that's being
done but yeah for any sort of some so
somewhat substantial change through the
jdk that goes through the Jep process
so for text blocks well um where I
provide I find it very beneficial is
well we've all had kind of to work with
code or some sort of formatted language
within
um our code as a string in this example
I'm just printing together a simple Json
message and we can quickly see how messy
it gets and of course we're all pretty
familiar with this and
um you know well we can probably see
what we're what's kind of going on in
here you know if it's just to be any
much more complex you know if there's
supposed to be some nesting down within
the Json message it quickly becomes very
difficult to maintain it can be very
easy to make a mistake it'd be very easy
to forget to add a comma at the end of a
line and you would never really notice
it and then we also have to do all the
escaping of quotes and then new lines
and all that stuff just to actually you
know properly format it of course we
don't necessarily have to do all this
stuff for it to be proper Json but to be
readable
um if we were to print it out this is
what we would need to do
with text blocks well text blocks are
simply two-dimensional strings where
also a lot of the formatting
requirements are reduced so a text box
is denoted by a triple quote a new line
and then within the enclosing triple
quotes again much of the formatting is
relaxed so we no longer need to have a
you know new line marker we don't have
to escape the double quotes we don't
have to put a bunch of tabs in here if
we want to have it tabbed and the way
also then is that the
um
I mean closing triple coats also plays a
big part in then what white space is
ignored so all the white space to the
left of this triple quotes is ignored
now this can also be a little bit
um there's a lot of particularies around
how the ignored white space is done if I
was to move the enclosing triple quotes
up it to the right then the in ignored
white space will just be based upon the
most left and our most left character
but all the same usually you just want
to keep these triple quotes aligned with
wherever
um your
string is located in closing or wherever
you just want the leftmost of that
string to be accepted but all the same
this white space here is all ignored so
that way it's that way so if I was to
have this within a method and then maybe
refactor the method to where it was
farther down
um uh more tabbed over all of a sudden
this string when it suddenly have a
bunch of more white space within it
but fundamentally text blocks are just
normal strings so if I wanted to do some
string formatting here that would work
just like it would with any other you
know a one-dimensional string
if you do want to have a carriage
returned ignored on the very last as a
very last character within that line you
would just put a backsplate or a
backslash make sure that it is the very
last character that you don't have any
sort of white space or anything after
that in which case that won't be
considered but then yeah it putting it
back to place our backslash at the very
end of the line will ignore it in this
case that
um
this text block is printed out as a
single line
the next item is the Swift's updates and
these are all added in Java 14 and their
Jep is 361.
so we're all familiar with the a switch
statement with the colon syntax and one
of the major issues of this is it's
pretty visually noisy as you can kind of
see here I have to kind of scroll a bit
to actually be able to properly sew this
entire switch case
and within this noise does come
opportunities for introduction of bugs
because switch has followed by fall
through by default often what this means
in practice is that each of your cases
are going to have to have a break
statement within them to prevent the
fall through but it can be very easy to
accidentally forget that maybe you're
doing some testing or maybe you're just
doing some refactoring and so maybe you
forget to put a break in one of the
cases or comment it out or something
like that and then you push it to
production and then all of a sudden you
have a bug in production because you hit
on k6 but then it also both prints out
you know Friday and then Saturday
um so with the updates is we added the
new Arrow operator and with that is if
it matches on a Case only the code to
the right of the error operator is
executed there is no fall through so
this allows it to be much cleaner in
appearance and then also just much more
easy to understand okay you're matching
on the case you're only executing
executing the code to the right of it
easy to understand
much more compact
switches can also now be written as an
expression so now when a match is made
on a case then that value is yielded out
of the switch
switch Expressions must be exhaustive so
that would often mean having to have a
default case included within a switch
expression
and then all the cases would either have
to be the type
a compatible type to what you
necessarily set up the expression to be
or a throw
um you can also if you wanted to execute
a block of code if just a single line
doesn't properly encapsulate what you
wanted to do you can also put braces
around it and then this will all be
executed when writing it as an
expression then you would need to use
the reserved word or is it Reserve type
word of yield it's not actually a
keyword so if you had yield in other
places of your code outside and switch
Express and it would still be valid you
wouldn't get a compiler error for using
it you can also use the curly braces to
execute multiple lines of code also
within a switch statement using the
error operator so if I wanted to execute
multiple lines of code I could put curly
braces around this but in that case you
wouldn't need to have a yield in it
because of course you're not yielding
any sort of value out of it
you can also write a switch expression
using the Cohen syntax so in words in
case like in this example you would have
it um each case and with a yield
as I mentioned though switch Expressions
they will often need are they are
exhausted exhaustive and so that would
often mean needing to include a default
case but for example in this with this
enum if I cover all of the different
values within the enum within my uh so
it's expressing then a default case is
no longer needed if I was to go and add
like another value to this enum if I you
know admitted a new day then you would
get a compiler error saying that this
switch case or sits expression is no
longer
exhaustive and of course that also works
with the old colon syntax as well so of
course you know this isn't forcing
everyone to use New Era operator and
I'll actually maybe see a new video
coming out uh to later today with the
sipa Java on some examples of how we're
in the Cohen syntax could still be valid
are still be very useful
so pattern matching for instance of this
is going to be a very important story
going forward within Java and this is
the first instance of it if you've heard
of project Amber so project Amber is
actually delivering many of these
language features I have just been
talking about earlier in the
presentation
its name actually comes from uh the a
series of books written back in the 80s
called The Chronicles of Amber where the
um a right of passage within that book
is called Walking the pattern and
pattern matching being an important
project Amber so it's just like
really figuring out when I learned about
that it's like wow I really am working
with some very hardcore nerds here at uh
part of the Java platform group
but for pattern matching for instance of
um instance of isn't the most commonly
used of operator or keywords within Java
but you know occasionally we've all had
to use it to where we have some sort of
variable that's of some type that could
just be one of many or just for some
reason unknowable as it's coming in in
this example I have like a number type
and I just wanted you know either it's
if they're integer long or a double and
so again somewhat visually noisy and
also that visual noise and for verbosity
um does become a bit of an opportunity
for adding errors because maybe I didn't
set up this casting within it but yeah
it's just like even though we know for
some number type has to be an integer I
still have to cast it to actually set
the variable integer I
um so pattern matching what it does is
it has a predicate here in this case we
still have the very familiar of a
variable if it's instance of a type and
then if it is then we have a pattern
variable in this case integer I and this
I is then flow scoped and so flow scope
is a New Concept to Java and what flow
scope is is that I is in scope wherever
the compiler definitely knows it has
been set effectively wherever this
predicate is true so often cases what
this is going to mean it's just in the
following if block to the code
um and we can then see here for a long
um L will then be in scope for the
following if lock and same with d and
this can be very useful because then
here in this example let's say I want to
test it for different sizes of the
letter
um of the integer I won't have to kind
of think up arbitrary different values
or different variable names I can
discontinue to use I because for the
compiler each I here is in fact a
different variable because
this cannot this cannot be in scope
where this is in scope so it just works
together very well to make it very clear
and again not having to think of like x
y z for each of these different if
statements just to make sure there's no
conflicts
um but there's a little bit more on Flow
scoping so like I said it's in scope
wherever the compiler definitely knows
it's true so it would be in scope within
this if block but outside of the if
block then it would be out of scope if I
just had an evaluation
um block then it would be uh I forgot I
need to update this code example but if
this was following it earlier with the
integer I I would be in scope here but
then would be allowscope immediately
once we leave that evaluation and it
would also be out of scope to the right
of an R statement
um if you wanted to get weird not that
you should do any of this because this
would be very confusing and very bug
prone um but if I was to put a knot in
front of this
um it would not be in scope within the
following if block bill would be in
scope in the else and if I was to do a
not and then throw an exception it would
actually be out in scope outside of the
if statements
um or the if block so not I would
recommend doing any of this but this
just kind of sews what flow scope is
involved with
um because if you did this this would be
very error prone because like some other
developer or you like two or three
months later is going to kind of look in
this code it's like what is going on
here so don't don't do these things but
this is to demonstrate what flow scope
actually works like it's not some sort
of arbitrary oh it's only in scope
following the if statement it has
rational logic to it
next up is sealed classes these were
added in Java 17 and their Jep is 409
and the main benefit I see in sales
classes I mean there's benefits Beyond
this but is a way to put into code
domain Concepts within your organization
so every organization I've been with
there's whatever kind of domain business
logic Concepts in this example I have
user where maybe within user there is
only you know certain number of
different kinds of users there could be
transaction types there could be uh you
know shipping types or are so many
different types you know you're kind of
familiar with the domain concepts of
your organization and there's never
really a way to demonstrate this in code
or so this encode both sealed classes
classes can now Define who can actually
extend them so in this case user is
saying only guest customer and admin can
extend them and within a sealed
hierarchy then
the implementing classes or the
extending classes would then have to
declare themselves a sealed non-sealed
are
are final and in this case guesses final
customer is non-sealed an admin is a
steel class which then allows two
different types of admin Systems off of
it so what this looks like in code then
is you would use a new keyword sealed
and of course in your class and then
there's the optional keyword of permits
where you would then Define any classes
that could extend off of the seal class
user and then as I mentioned
all of the subclasses would then have to
declare themselves as either non-sealed
which is in a case of customer which
effectively makes it a normal class
where any sort of class could then
extend off a customer
next in we would have you could also
have final which you know we're all
familiar with and
um you know in the case of guests are
then you could also have a seal class or
a subclass of a steel class also be
sealed itself as in cases with admin
um so as I mentioned earlier permits is
optional and so if you wanted to have
classes defined outside of the source
file of a sealed class then you would
use the permits Clause if you were to
Define classes within the same source
file as a sealed class then the compiler
will automatically assume that these are
the only classes that can extend off of
it in which case actually if I try to
put permits in here it would actually
result in a compile error so you can do
either permits to reference external
files or external classes or forego it
and then Define the classes within the
same source file
and the last new language feature is
records and these were added in Java 16
their chip is 395. the first benefit
that you know developers or really
notice with records is reducing our
boilerplate reduction though you know
briefly cover your ears for one second
there Nikolai but yeah here is in this
brief or this example of you know maybe
I'm doing some sort of data
transformation and so I have you know a
few variables and I would like to put
them within this person class now even
defining a simple class takes up dozens
of lines if I want to you know have a
Canon Constructor of course defining the
the fields themselves the equals and so
on
um and if I was to try to find this
within the body of a method well quickly
the context of that method is all lost
because that just becomes completely
dominated by the definition of this
class
with records I get all that I had in
that previous example of the person but
I can Define that within a single line
now I'm sure as Nikolai is steaming up
over there Michael is a colleague on my
on the Java devrel team
um you know records the point of them is
not to reduce boil plate but to be able
to transparently model data as data so
when we Define a record just within that
definition we already know really all we
need to know about that record we know
its name we know all the different
fields within that record and we know
this because of their several
constraints within our record a record
superclass this is always going to be
like record so you can't extend it it's
abstract and it's implicitly final so
we're not going to get any sort of
inherited logic or inherited behavior
from some sort of superclass all the
fields within record are records are
final but this is only cellularly
immutable so if you were to use like an
array or an array list or something like
that and you decided to change a value
you within that array array list then
that could still be done but you're just
going to change the reference that you
are using you can also not declare
instance Fields So within the curly
braces here when the definition of a
record I can of course Define other
methods and stuff like that but I
couldn't put another instance field
within there because then that will
violate the being able to look at the
definition of a record to understand
what you need to know about it
so what this constraints come benefits
so the compiler will automatically
generate the accessor's house code to
string and equals all automatically
generated you can also override these
default implementations like you can
override passcode or two string or
equals to add your own definitions but
of course as you do that make sure that
particularly like hash code and equals
that you're still fulfilling the goals
of those methods to otherwise you're
going to run into some serious issues
and it's also why certain things like
arrays probably should be avoided within
records because arrays like default
compare by value or compare by reference
not by value so if you had it had two
records and they had equivalent values
within it they would not be equal if
you're using an array so definitely
consider using lists instead of an array
if you do need that kind of need
um but yeah here in this example I'm
overriding two string just to something
that maybe prints out a little bit
prettier than the square Brack brackets
and then each value
um or of course I could Define my own
method as well because fundamentally
records are just normal classes
um so I mentioned how records they can't
be extended but they can Implement
interfaces so here in this example in
fact I'm doing like a sealed interface
so seal classes can do our sealed
classes can be both interfaces and
classes and then I have different
records each implementing shape as well
within it
so uh API updates so first is the
enhanced pseudo-random number generators
um this was done also in jdk 17 it's
Jeff is 356 and so before there was four
different interfaces or there still is
for for interfaces and they all had
somewhat similar behavior and somewhat
similar API but they weren't exactly the
same uh and that just created some
frustration if you wanted to move from
one splitable type or from one random
random type like splitable jumpable
leapable or arbitrarily jumpable to the
other it wasn't a simple of changing the
import you would actually have to go
through and make several other changes
so now all these have a uniform API
across them or as uniform as is
practical because of course there is
certain things like arbitrarily jumpable
where you would Define how much you
would jump across that random generator
so you know it would have additional API
that may not be present in other
but along with this is the underlying
algorithms have been also updated being
more secure and generally it'd be best
if you're needing a secure random
generation just to use the defaults
because with every release these
algorithms are also updated
the internet address resolution SPI this
is at end job at 17 18 and its ship is
418 and this is probably some of the
changes are coming with things like Loom
now this is going to be kind of
interesting this is actually a somewhat
larger crowd that I usually present to
but usually it always comes out to so
how many people are familiar with the
Java service loader
that it that's the way it almost always
goes there's always like two or three
people regardless of the room size you
know if there's a thousand people who
probably you know so only be two or
three people
um but the way it does work is through
the Java servers loader
um and this can be very useful for
testing so by default
um we've all had kind of work where you
would need maybe update the hostname
file on your computer to be like hey you
know if it says localhost or if it says
this IP address then to actually
reference to this
um URL or this other location
um now instead of having to do that you
can actually provide like your own
definition to where and this can be very
good for testing support uh are also the
various Frameworks that they can provide
their own way of resolving internet
addresses
um fundamentally this is mainly done to
support Loom which we'll talk about a
little bit later because it's going to
be changing up how we it uses threads
and that just want to be practical the
default Behavior though of Internet
address resolution will still remain the
same it will still use the built-in
platform resolver so it's not a a
default performance or behavior change
but there are very um there are benefits
Beyond just being able to support Loom
and the code Snippets in Java API so
if you were to want to sew an example of
how to use like a method or an API
within your code within javadoc you
would use the code snippet tag but that
was just all done with using HTML to
actually then render the
um
code example and then that also wasn't
discoverable by the Java compiler so
there was some sort of
um of a bug within the code like you
know just you forgot a semicolon or
parentheses or anything like that
that wouldn't be discoverable and you
know it could eventually get out of sync
with the axle code the new snippet tag
this is discoverable by the Java
compiler it's not by default you would
need like a framework or a tool to
actually then do that sort of validation
you can also reference external files as
well and these are automatically
discoverable as long as you set the
source path but most of the time you're
going to be using like a tool like Maven
or Gradle which is automatically setting
a source path for you but this can just
be a good way of be able to sew more
complex examples and also having them be
able to be validated by the Java
compiler to make sure sure that they are
valid examples as well
simple web server I'm actually running
this presentation on the simple web
server whoops as you can see here so
it's 127 8000 or the Blue Back address
at 8 000 that is where this is served
from but fundamentally uh
you know for doing some simple uh
like when students are learning how to
use Java often a early example is just
to serve some files up on a HTTP server
and before it would have to either go
you know get like download a separate
server or you know use something like
Tomcats just to kind of simulate just a
simple web server
um or are you something else now the
point of the J web server is just to be
as little ceremony as possible just you
know running from the command line
um jweb server to start it up and like I
said it starts up the loopback address 8
000 and it will serve the files from
whatever current directory in and the
mime types will be Auto configured so if
you have HTML it will be served as text
HTML if you hit like dot Java then that
would just be served as text plane
it is configurable though if you were to
do Dash B you can change the binding
address Dash D to change the directory
but you must include the full path and
you can also have a remote directory
even and you can use Dash o to change
the output level for logging
um one last thing
um
the javadoc has been updated to where it
will show updates and changes to classes
packages methods and all that
um here this is for the Java 18 because
Java 19 well it's published under early
release but it's just a bit easier to
use this URL but this is a really good
way to see some of the new methods and
stuff that have been added to various
classes particularly something like
string has actually seen a lot of
updates over recent releases that have
actually improved its usability for
example like removing forward padding or
padding at the end of a line there's
even things like is blank now that's
been added to string so definitely check
that out for maybe often used classes or
just to see like hold on you know Billy
mentioned how there's these new record
generators but what was the names of
them this can be actually a really good
way of finding that information
um let's get into runtime features and
improvements uh CDs uh updates so who
here has used class data sharing
only a few so many more people need to
use it so class data setting is a really
nice feature for improving the startup
time
um what's really particularly
interesting was added in jdk 13 which is
dynamic CDs archive where it made it a
very simple process for creating a
dynamic archive or creating a Sarah
archive so what happens at startup is
the Java the jvm loads a bunch of
classes from the jdk as this core
classes to start up and then this stack
goes all the way back into A5 and jdk9
they added app CDs which allows that
behavior to be extended into the actual
application you're starting
um and so of course every time you're
starting this up this is like the same
process so there's obviously room for
improvement
so in jdk9 this is made easier to where
it's only a two-step process now to
where if you start your application up
one time
um and using the
um jvm ARG our jvm flag archive classes
and exit the jvm will read all the
classes it loads and then once you exit
out or you end the jvm then it will
create this Dynamic Archive of all the
classes that need to be loaded
and then he started it up again with
shared archive file then pointing to
that location where you create that
archive file it will load from there you
know it's going to vary a lot depending
upon that pre the application you're
doing what you're doing at startup you
know if you're part of the startup
process it's actually you know reaching
out to connect to and run a database you
know that's going to infect your startup
but uh for example if I'm just running
like a simple spring boot application
off of my laptop here it's about a 10
reduction in startup time which is
pretty good and this is also very
robust to where if
um the this shared archive file can't be
found then the jvm will just silently
ignore it and then load the classes from
the from the file system instead so it's
not like it can't find it and it'll
crash also the jvm will only load the
classes that it actually needs and this
is helpful is that a lot of times at
organizations our teams we use a very
similar Tech stack across applications
you're probably going to be using spring
boot across media applications into
quarkis are our Micronaut or whatever it
might be and so with that is that the
vast majority of the classes that you're
actually going to be running in
production aren't classes that you wrote
yourself but are from the underlying
dependencies so what this means is
really what you can do is for whatever
your tax act just create one Dynamic
archive and then just use it for all the
other ones because then the jvm will
only load the classes that it needs from
it and so that way you won't have to be
managing a bunch of different archives
you know and updating them every time
you rebuilt an application that's going
to really be necessary
but yeah definitely check out app CDs
it's it's not talked about enough and
since things like startup are often
talked about as ways for improvement
well this is a very easy way of doing
that that is also very safe as well
ztc uh Z doesn't stand for anything it's
just the letter they chose for
um this garbage collector and this was
added in jdk15 it's Jeff is 377.
um the goals of GGC was low latency so
initially when it was released back in
jdk 15 it I always tried to keep it to
under a 10 millisecond polish time then
in jdk 16 they had another update to it
and now it's less than one millisecond
and that doesn't even really describe it
because about the max pause times for
GTC is about 250 microseconds and the
average pause time is about 25
microseconds and really importantly that
doesn't matter just the size of the Heap
so and it's scalable from about I think
50 megabytes to 16 terabytes and that
pause time should be consistent rather
it's on the very small end or on the
very high end it's currently single
generation but it's planned to become
multi generation soon but yeah to get
started check it out use the jvm r flag
ucdc set your HEAP space heapsace is one
of the most important areas that was
that will affect the performance of zgc
you want to make sure it's at least
enough for both all the live set of what
you're working on and then a bit above
that just so the GGC can actually
perform garbage collection
um
the the trade offers agency is it does
have somewhat slightly reduced
throughput compared to G1 usually it's
about 10 percent reduction in
throughputs uh but yeah if you're going
to use cgc also consider turning on
guard reads collection logging as well
just to see what's going on and this is
a really great presentation by prelinden
he used to run the zdc team
helpful null pointers I think this is
going to be something that makes every
Java developer very happy these were
added in JK 14 but yes we've all ran
into the very frustrating npe and the
worst mpes was when they happen on some
line to where multiple values on that
line could be a possible candidate for
being null and so before all we would
get back is saying like hey a null
happened on line 14 of your application
of your class and you'd be like okay now
I have to you know do another production
build to put some more logging in here
to see what was actually null
um and then actually didn't fix it later
on with like a subsequent bill but now
it will actually so here that oh nope
this this my record was null on this
line and so that this will make MPS just
a little less frustrating to deal with
armed architecture 64 support as of jdk
17 all the major platforms now have
armed architecture 64 support uh Mac OS
was the last with jdk 17 Windows just
before with jdk 16 and arm architecture
64 support is just going to be an
ongoing thing every release of the jdk
does come with farther support of it
uh one thing I don't I don't want to get
into specific numbers just because it's
going to vary so much depending upon
your application your hardware and so
many other factors but definitely one
thing to always consider is there's
pretty significant performance
improvements with every release and they
start to build up over time so certainly
if you're still on jdk 8 by moving to
jdk 17 you would notice a pretty
substantial Improvement across every
kind of performance category whether
it's startup throughput pause times
memory footprint and kind of any other
kind of smaller areas performance
um you would you should see pretty
significant improvements and even if
you're finding it difficult to talk to
management or higher levels of your
organization as to why improve and it's
not like if you want to get something
outside of just a cool new language
features you really want to use like
records performance is definitely a
really big one particularly if you're
running on public Cloud you know that
could be a pretty substantial cost
savings
so let's get into some deprecation
removal and other changes and this will
also again be pretty interesting because
usually it's only one or two people
regardless of room size but how many
people have used the security manager
again yeah one or two or three yeah
that's about right so that's part of the
reason why it's getting removed is that
despite it being around since the
induction of the jdk it's rarely used
and the fundamental reasons well there's
two major reasons why it's being removed
first is somewhat difficult to use
um it's this pretty difficult to go
through and say for each package you
know what kind of performance or what
kind of privileges you want to have at
and fundamentally the major reason the
security manager was there is for
running third-party
um foreign code within an application
well that's going away because applet
API is also being removed so that was a
primary reason it was there is when
applets were still very much a thing is
that if you had your jvm you're bringing
in this external code to suddenly run it
you had no idea whether that code could
be trusted or not or you can be certain
about that so you'd be like okay only
these packages only these classes and so
on would have these privileges in this
external code you know may would have
reduced privileges but that's just not
the way we build and run Java
applications anymore again apple adpi is
being is deprecated for removal along
with security manager
so security manager also just kind of
lost its relevance as well and there's
just a substantial cost to supporting
the security manager as well
and jdk 18
finalizers were also deprecated for
removal as well these are all just
deprecated for removal they haven't been
removed yet you know it's ongoing when
that's going to happen it's probably
going to be several years so if you are
using the security manager or applied
API or finalizers
move off of them as fast as possible but
it's not going to be like removed in jdk
19 or anything like that
on things that actually have been
removed have been the nas horn
JavaScript engine
um it still exists it's so supported
um you can actually go to open jdk the
open jdk GitHub Nas horn and it's still
there they're still getting some support
to it but it's just no longer packaged
within the jdk itself
um the cmat the CMS garbage collector uh
concurrent Mark sweep it fundamentally
was just superseded by the G1 garbage
collector which became the default
garbage collector back in jdk9 so it was
removed CMS and jdk 14.
um the other important changes to know
about is starting jdk9 with the
introduction of the Java module system
started the
um process of more strongly
encapsulating jdk internals and we're
seeing a another big step in that which
ATK 17 Works jdk internals are done by
Dr are now strongly encapsulated so back
in jdk 9 illegal access permits to make
that process of moving from jdk 8 to 9
and above a bit easier was set as a
default jvm argument which effectively
disabled the reflection prevention
mechanisms within the module system
um in jdk 16 illegal access permit was
no longer a default argument and now
with jdk 17 illegal access permit is a
no-op
um civil apis are still available like
sun misc unsafe and a few others so that
will help ease the process of
um taking in this chains and you can
also still do things like ads opens as
well to get reflective access into a
module if needed
all right I'm going to go through this
quick because we're running quickly
running out of time
um so preview and updater uh pattern
matching for switch is coming or is
going to be in store preview for Java
19. the big changes were some changes to
how in all cases are handled and then
also now when pattern matching
um there's now Unwin Clause that
replaces the guard Clause using
ampersands to the and and like and
operator
record patterns um during the first
preview for Java 19. and so now it can
be much easier to extract values out of
a pattern so if here's an example of if
an instance is matching on point or
object O is a point I can just directly
reference the fields within that record
to get the values out of them the
matching is based on the location in the
field so the variable names even though
I have X and Y for in both cases here
they could be arbitrary names I could
you know this could be Be A and B and it
would still match on it it's just going
to be matching on the type and then the
location within the record
virtual threads
finally Loom is making it into the main
line of the jdk and virtual threads are
now in their first preview for jdk 19.
um you know virtual threads or Loom is
going to allow for that massive
horizontal scalability of java and it's
going to allow us to have that
a familiar coating imperative coating
that we're familiar with instead of
having to use reactive coding which is a
little bit more difficult for most Java
developers to kind of work with as well
as a little bit more difficult to debug
or caught one of my colleagues Jose
palmard he has two really great videos
on that if you go to our YouTube channel
on Virtual threads so definitely check
that out to get some more depth on it
and it starts a concurrency
um as my colleague Nikolai parlog
suggested they go together like peanut
butter and jelly
um so what store currency does is if you
want to have a task broken up into
parallel Behavior but when I have it be
part of like a consistent coding block
structure concurrency can enable that
um that behavior and then also have them
to kind of come together into a single
result also we had our Nikolai covers
that in a great inside Java newscast
that was released about a month ago now
right something about a month ago again
you can check out our YouTube channel to
kind of get a bit more of a description
on that and the vector API if you're
needing to do some math or like image
processing or speech processing
something I've never really done too
much before the vector API is now in its
fourth incubator and it's going to
continue to be in incubator status until
Valhalla is actually going to be
um start seeing um its inclusion into
the main line just because Valhalla the
the changes to the valley type system
um it's going to so fundamentally impact
how Vector that Vector API works that
it's not going to make sense to finalize
a vector API until Valhalla itself is
also delivered
and I guess it also forgot to include
the foreign Linker and foreign memory
apis have also been updated or moved to
preview status in jdk 19. with that said
um these are some links as I mentioned
the
um of the jeps for all of them uh I do
have the release notes for 18. obviously
19 is not out yet but once that's
released it would just simply be the
same URL just change it to 19. I
mentioned we I do a super Java a one
minute video every Monday you can kind
of see them all here also I know they're
one of the biggest concerns is moving
beyond uh Java a kind of dealing with
the Java module system this is a really
great article from a former Netflix
engineer uh Carl Massillon I'm not going
to mispronounce his last name but
um he talked about the difficulties
um his team or at least where he was was
at Netflix and moving beyond Java 8 like
it you know people were saying like oh
it's impossible to move to Java 11 and
the big takeaway is really the biggest
thing is just updating your your
underlying dependencies really something
you kind of want to do anyways for both
security and performance reasons
um and you know occasionally May mean
having to make some coding changes to
you know handle the new API updates to
the dependencies or sometimes you may
have to switch out a dependency because
it's not supported in jdk of Beyond Java
8 which you know is something again you
probably wouldn't do anyways because it
probably means it's starting to get out
of date and then could be running into
some potential security issues
um with that said we still have about
five minutes for questions or is it is
it 12 o'clock when the next one starts
or is there
okay we have five minutes for questions
so yeah do we have three questions in
the web app that I encourage you to use
it to make questions
yeah go ahead and subscribe and then we
can get to the question
yeah the first one uh what will be the
future of yava versioning we did stay
same with the Halford year Cadence or
would it be change anyhow
uh to my knowledge it's still going to
maintain that uh six-month Cadence it
seems to have been very successful
certainly the Java core team is also
um really like the six month Cadence so
that should be saying the same
the next one should we perhaps expect
Java core or similar in the future
uh I'm not quite sure what what's being
asked by Java core or is that referring
to like.net core or something like that
I don't know I don't have any more
information okay I'm not sure well maybe
it will be fun who wrote it later yeah
the last one what will be the future of
java version in oh again no with this
station okay two times it's something
important okay
uh what is the biggest problem you see
in the transition from java 11 to Java
19.
uh luckily the trends like from eight to
eleven
um is a difficult one just between
underlying dependencies and then at
least some of the concerns when it comes
to the Java module system but generally
what I've heard or what we've heard back
from industry that getting from 8 to 11
is difficult but gains from 11 beyond is
pretty easy and really if you're up
oriented like 17 getting to 17 to 18 18
and 19 is actually a pretty easy
transition generally so cool any more
questions
um okay yeah so back there can you go to
the microphone well
I want it to work
both too well
um so probably is a question doesn't
make a lot of sense but let's say your
library has a sealed class and I want to
extend it or obviously in the C Class
you say permits x y z and I'm
I don't have the access to your source
code and your sales card is another
library but I still want to do kind of
something extended what would be the
good practice here well for like a seal
class you said yeah exactly yeah so you
assessing class user permits I don't
know employee person blah blah blah and
now in my code I don't have access I
just your code is in some other Library
I obviously I don't have access to the
source code I can't change it so I still
want to use it somehow I want to extend
it in a sense so do how can I make this
happen how does it so so you're saying
you want so there's like a sealed
hierarchy and there's like some class
that you then want to extend from it
that it doesn't well part of that is to
prevent that from happening you know
like a like a framework or a library
maintainer and be like no I don't want
to allow any other class that's using
this library to extend it because then
that could violate some of the behavior
of the class now you can potentially
depending upon those subclasses how that
are fine like if they're non-seal
classes you could extend off of them but
you know part of the point point of
steel Hocker is to prevent people from
arbitrarily extending classes foreign
feel free to come up or like you know
grab me in the hallway or of course also
you can
um reach out to me via Twitter or email
so anyways thanks for uh coming
[Applause]